[音楽]
ren
tee
me
経営塾志木高等学校のお金子です
今日話すことは簡単に言えばわかるとできるの違いになるんですね
ってこのはカレットできるの順位ということについて話させていただきたいんですが
その前にまず簡単に自己紹介させていただきたいと思います
私はよっちゃから co haroo さんなんですが
photo 指圧2 f yus チーリンとグードゥジュールライダーですが
大当たり十両6出身校で有名なハーフ cram school 世界中の方向性
が集まりましてボンちゃんピースというテーマについて
グループディスカッションや体験型学習を通して何か学んでいくというプログラムに
なっています
日本から4校参加したですよま ko からわし機構の皆さん化となりました
この際人らしき交換が参加した生徒になります私が唯一の3年生ということでこの子
機構のメンバーのリーダー的ポジションをやらせていただきました
えーまた s gli はビスへい雷で学んだことを以前館のプロジェクトで社会に
貢献スーパー歓迎するということで現在このヘルプマークというマークの
プロモーションを行っております猫のヘルプ正拳ついては皆さんも手元の冊子に挟ん
やったらチラシをご覧下さい
プーレが
捕獲したいことがあるね発売させていただきます
じゃあ一度本題に戻りまして何で私がわかるとできるの違いについて話そうかと思った
という感ということについてなのですがこれ sg 雷で感じたリーダーの理論と実践
のズレというところが
いきたいとなっております
sg られるプログラムの一つで自分のもリーダーズを送る上で一つの便利仕上げると
いう課題があったんですがこの時私の中にあるリーダーがこうあるべきだという
アイディアがあったので他のグループのメンバーと話し合って1枚形に仕上げることが
できました
しかし実際にハワイいう現地の方で日本に帰ってからどのようなプロジェクトやれかと
いうことについて紫紺会まあかなチャンた際にどういう風にしたらあと4個メンバーの
アイディアうまく1つにまとめられるかということに遺憾気力がなくなってしまって
実践リーダーとしてうまく金をしていた9回いた結果
になってしまいましたん
山の分かりとできるは何が違うのでしょうか
このわかるとできるの違いについて考えるためにまず二色の獲得から習得まで仲良くの
4段階に分けて考えてみようと思います
やまず知らないという状態ですね物理世界に好まれが情報だと思ってくださいでこの
矢印あんま情報の流れまあロジックみたいなもんだと思ってこれを見てください
知らないという状態では物理世界にあるこのような情報やロジックについて自分の頭の
中で
に存在することがありませんしかし知っているという状態でそのロジックの中に出て
くる情報
vics 関心というのは聞いたことあるという状態に近い状態になります
そして別れという状態では赤身よりアウェって言うよ見てそれを食べることができるの
ですがこの時
赤緑合うというものをパターンとしてパクがあったら青学れなるということには官とし
認識してしまうため
方の中にあかんあったら青になるということだけが記憶されます
そのため医師の中に赤可能という
もしかないので実際に物理世界で髪や言葉としてこの赤青というもの従いダメ墓緑ある
という情報を出力することができません
なしで生きるという状態ですできるという状態は情報の関係性ロジックを法定それを
自分の頭で理解してそれを頭の中に取得していることができるよねこれ完璧に物理世界
にで出力することができます
エルゴン時受注となってくれるファクターが
咀嚼ということになります
うんわかる人ができる人なので理解をパターンについて
クラブジェイミーとみようと思います移り世界先ほどの女王にプラスして他の情報が
複数あったとします
て公的わかる人の理解は赤だったら版が降るというようにパターンリンチしてそれを
覚えているため
バカが来たじゃあを弾っていうふうに頭が
ハイロジックを見せることはできるんですが他の情報について何がどうなっていうのが
よくわからないので
えっ
なにこれでいう状態になってしまうのが分かる人です
キャディーとはどういうことかということを考えていきます生きる人は赤だったら緑
合うだなんて言いロジック自分の頭に一度言い介してそれを自分の方にしているため
赤み4分老人の戦艦物流系朝結果の情報に関し4コーナーから今たらコーナーじゃない
かティチェ
自分の中で情報のネットワークロジックを整理して組み立てることができます
bouvet ている通り
情報を情報としてだけで4パラ
ブーブーそれ覚えた情報カーン
その路地
口を見ているためその他の情報に関してもロジックな声音無視することができます
つまり情報思い通りに選択して流れを作り出しているということになります
じゃあなぜ分かる膝できないのでしょうか
そのことについて私は今コレだぜだったね笑ってほしかったんですけどあのむしろいけ
なかったですごめんなさい
やることは並ぶことっていうことが挙げられます
えっとは壁人は外から情報をもらっているつまり間接的や直接的な状態でなかっている
ということになるんですがこれはであることではすでにある情報やその他の人が持って
いる二色の情報のストップを道部コピーすることができます
しかしその中でまだ21の施工でありますと
その情報と情報のショートカットを作成できてもどういう絶景話が展開しているのかと
いうことについては理解できないので情報のミットワークが構築できませんつまり
パターン認識型の思考つまりわかる人の思考パターンで言いますと
過去に何かがそこのた至高の劣化版を自分の頭の中に息することしかできないのです
てい
そこで重要になってくるのが創作ですなぜ咀嚼が重要になってくるかといいますと
いすれに人が行った考えについて自分の言葉で考え直してみる
そして自分なりに理解することによって越前に行われた思考自分の志向として自分の中
に取得することができるのです
このそ作はどうすればいいかといいますとお勧めの方法としてブレインストーミングが
ありますこれ実際私がハワイで行った方法に
なのですがあるキーワードについて他の関連するワード
オフィス皆さんを見つけると思うんですがそのふわぁとりあえず神回避あ関連性がある
が関連静画
あるワード5位停戦を引っ張ってみるんですね阻止すると会津
情報からする意見花火てみる情報に見て関しましても
実は選挙結ばれているということに気づいてい気づき
情報を合理的に食べる流れが見えてくるんですねその音声合理的にたどる流れこそが
考えということになり
ます
そこそそもそもの話なんて考え持つ必要があるのか何で分かるじゃダメでできるて
なきゃいけないのかということについてです
それは考えというものは情報 c 的な中止であるんですか
この情報は感情や文化などのバイアス受けて抽出されます
へつまり人によって考えられ
違うということは人がそれまでに蓄積してきた meme の違いつまりその人が反映
できたり人生の違いが考えに現れるということになります
この自分なりの考えを g さらに他の人の考えを咀嚼して自分のものにすることに
よってもその情報を自分が咀嚼してで企業になってなければ自分が生タクシーなあかん
だことも自分のな
かで考えとして選択肢の一つに蓄えることができます
いつもあり様々考え酌して自分のものにすることによって自分の人生の選択でき自分の
人生をコントロールできるようになるということです
今までの話をまとめさせていただきますとこれから重要になってくるの
さまざま皆さんついに会話や授業などさまざまなところで考えを一曲一から受け取って
いると思います
この考えについてしっかりできるかすることによっピースの考えを自分のものにできる
つまり考えをできるとすることに
でその他の人が持っていた人生経験それまた
meme などを全て自分のものにできてそこで初めてその考えを焼くと自分の持って
きたっていうふうになります
ですみませんがわかりにくい話だったんですがんで非正常皆さんに私の今回の話を
できるか
ていただけたらなと思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]